So we don't yet know whether Ron DeSantis,
the Republican Florida governor, is going
to enter the race and challenge Donald Trump's
seemingly unchangeable path to the Republican
nomination. One guy we know is running is Vivek
Ramaswamy. And I'm going to play for you. We're
not going to spend a lot of time on this. This
is basically just almost satire at this point.
Vivek Ramaswamy was interviewed on Fox News and he
now is jumping into the tears in my eyes stories.
I don't understand what the obsession is with with
people crying for these Republicans. But you may
know that Trump is known for telling stories, most
of which we believe are made up of people coming
to him, crying with tears in their eyes. And Eric
Trump sometimes will jump into it. Donald Trump
will sometimes tell these stories. And the way
these stories go, as you know, Eric Trump will
say, listen, I boarded a JetBlue flight the
other day. I fly commercial all the time.
And as I boarded, everybody stood up and cheered
and a couple of guys came up to me and they were
crying and they were saying, You've been treated
so unfairly. We've got your dad's back. And then
usually we listen to that story and we go. Nobody
was doing that. Nobody. Nobody burst into tears on
a JetBlue flight over Eric Trump just being there.
So anyway, it's that with Tears in my Eyes
stories. Vivek Ramaswamy now claims. That at one
of his events a guy came in wearing a MAGA shirt.
The guy went up to ask a question, started crying,
and then abandoned, supporting Trump and decided
to support Vivek Ramaswamy. Our friend Aaron
Rupert tweeted filed this under things that didn't
happen. Take a listen to this. One of the people
who actually stood up at that same event was
somebody who walked in with the Trump shirt. Broke
down in tears as he asked the question, thinking
about the country and what we were doing for his
children. Said he was switching over to vote for
me. Absolutely. Running for the presidency. Could
that possibly be true? Like it or not, it also
honestly. There's nothing wrong with crying. There
is nothing wrong with crying. And if anything,
we maybe have a lot of people who have been sort
of culturally conditioned not to express emotion.
So this is not about there's nothing wrong with
crying. But what what sort of circumstances would
lead to you being a Trump supporter? But
you go, I'm going to go to Vivek's event,
but I'm going to wear my MAGA shirt. And then
when they do questions, you say, even though I'm
a Trump supporter, I'm going to ask a question.
And then in the course of asking the question,
you're so overcome with emotion for how wonderful.
What Vivek is proposing is a guy who's polling,
what, 3% that you break down in tears and say, I'm
abandoning my support for Trump and now I support
you while crying. It's either an obvious lie or
a sign of extraordinary emotional instability.
Nothing wrong with crying. That scenario strikes
me as bonkers, totally and completely bonkers.
So do we believe this? I don't believe it.
I don't believe it. You tell me whether
you think that story could even possibly be
true. The David Pacman Show is, of course,
an audience supported program. We really just
will do this for as long as people want us to
do it. And for as long as we have the resources
to do it. And much of that comes from you by
signing up at Join Pacman dot com, we offer the
commercial free show every single day in audio
or video form to all of our members. We also do an
extra show every single day called The Bonus Show,
and we have a whole bunch of other great perks
you can read about at Join Pacman, NBC.com.